um I'm pavitra I work as a developer
Advocate atsite I'll be a primary
instructor today and uh uh I have with
me Kim she's my co-presenter uh Kim is a
software engineer at consite um as well
so she's my colleague uh she's going to
be here to help with any questions
youall have so this is a tutorial and
this is a Hands-On tutorial so we're
going to get started with setting up um
your hands-on experience so in the chat
which is the
session chat uh I'll share a
link to uh the set of instructions which
we can walk through
together
there where do I see all the attendees
oh people in the session we have a lot
of people I I see now
okay hi
everyone this is interesting uh all
right so if you go to that link uh that
I've shared in the chat you will hop on
to this uh Google doc yeah I see a lot
of folks are here so um how many people
do we have actually like do we have a
clear number can't tell so we have about
50 50 instances uh uh allocated so if
you go to the very first spreadsheet
like it's the first point here and open
it up um yeah so if you put your name
against one of these instances um you
can just take
that username and we have uh we have 50
allocated right now so uh if this is
full um I think Kim can also drop in the
chat if folks aren't able to log in at
some point um if this is full uh you can
still follow along uh but you may not be
able to just do this Hands-On because
all of the tutorial materials are
designed to work on like like work we
work with really large data sets on like
a cluster of machines which may not
which not everyone will have access to
okay so I'm going to let folks do this
quickly and while you do that I'll just
walk you through how to sign up right so
uh yeah go in uh just add your name
against one of these usernames and make
sure to just uh keep this tab open so
that you have a reference um and then
you can on you can you can navigate to
training. site. there is a link in the
doc this open oh I I already have it
open um but you will see a log window
with uh sign in to keycloak and there
you can use like P data your number
right that you SED and the default
password which is given here in the doc
I'll actually just increase the F yeah
that should be more visible to everyone
um okay so once you sign in you'll be
prompted to change your username sorry
your password um so just remember the
changed like your the password that you
set because you will need that password
once uh during this tutorial like you
may need it for like uh stting into the
Das dashboard which we'll look at in a
bit okay so just keep your password on
hand um but once you hop in you will see
a start my server button um so and
you'll see like niari that's that's when
you know your signing authentication
process is complete uh click on start my
server and select the medium instance
you're going to need uh like small is
going to be very slow for this tutorial
so we need medium all right on medium
and hit
start after that uh actually you know
what tell me in the chat I guess once uh
you've started your instance and then
we'll do uh we'll get the tut tutorial
materials cloned in the uh in this
instance and also if you have any
questions uh and I went by a little fast
so if something isn't clear just please
please ask us this is the most important
step right like this is once you have
the tutorials then it's going to be
smooth sailing because we have a clear
there
okay how many people
have yeah we have a few
folks
yeah uh right
so the next step like once you're
in in the instance and you started your
like medium instance you will be you
you'll be in a Jupiter lab windows so
folks are familiar with jupit lab this
should be like pretty much you know what
you know um there you can open your
terminal so the terminal for folks who
are not aware will be in the uh the last
section in the launcher the launcher
should be open but the moment you like
are are dropped into the instance right
uh if not if the launcher isn't open let
me just close this one and uh yeah if
the launcher isn't open if you can just
click the plus button here or you should
be able to get the launcher from file
new launcher as well um and the terminal
is available in under
other open the terminal and
write uh get
clone repo so did you did you say the
password
uh yeah I didn't say it out loud I think
but it's available here it's nibari
capital n nibari capital user
exclamation 3 2 1 and uh the at theate
at symbol so that's the password and
then the user names are what is shown in
the Excel spreadsheet so the usernames
are pi dator onecore two and all you're
doing is claiming a a username um
because we only have so many usernames
available so we have 50 usernames
available so what you're doing here is
you're just going to claim a username by
writing your name or something in the
your name line or your name column and
then you'll log on to um the nabari
instance using that username and then
the password from the Google Doc great
yeah thanks for
clarifying yeah always U maybe just let
us know once youall have like signed in
so uh we can move
on
okay yeah we were at cloning right so
yeah the moment you clone the repo
should be available in the sidebar uh in
the file Navigator here
uh you can open it and go to uh
introduction or intr task and like
follow along with us as we as we walk
through these one by
one
okay I think that's
um that's about it like if in case you
like close the browser tab or something
you can just go back to training. s.dev
um and log in with the same username and
password that you set right uh and all
the material like any even the work you
do should be in a saved State
there okay uh I think
have yeah got up okay now we can then
get started with the tutorial U I'll do
like another uh just extended intro I
guess uh and let more folks do the setup
um so the the platform you're using is
nibari both Kim and I are uh nibari
maintainers I think yeah C team members
um
and this tutorial um just make sure the
environment that we have or the kernel
if you're familiar with Jupiter lab uh
we'll be using the uh global global P
Global like this is just uh the way
nebari handles environments this this
environment is in the global Nam space
um if you're interested in environments
there is another talk tomorrow which I'm
presenting about a packaging and
environment magic that goes on behind
the scenes um but we won't be going to
environments today just make sure if in
case this is not set it should be the
default selected for you in case if it's
not uh you can select this environment
and everything should be good to go okay
um that's the main bit and there are
some exercises um uh the environment
name that's game okay thank you
yeah uh there are some exercises here
we'll we'll stop for the exercises or we
may continue based on like timing and
yeah how much how how fast or slow we go
today all right so uh with all of the
setup done we can jump
into
task so this is
the before we even get into this like in
this tutorial our main goal is to just
give a very practical like very um uh
getting our intuition right view of Big
Data analysis right and we are going to
focus mainly on like tabular data um so
not so much dumpy but more panda style
uh and the two main libraries that we
use here are task and HP plot these are
the libraries we are super familiar with
but uh we are generally thinking about
just how to work with big data in a
parallel distributed manner so we hope
most of the inclusions can carry over to
uh any other framework you use as well
but focusing on the these two libraries
in particular okay so uh let's start
with um actually yeah also this is we
initially the first version of this
tutorial was a 4-Hour tutorial so we
have condensed this down and like
because we've presented that a couple of
times we realize you know we can
condense it down to a way and like make
the even more digestible right so um a
good preliminary thing is before we
start with any big data analysis it's
useful to work with a subset of the data
set um if it's just easier to work with
you can work with you can use your local
computers um like any Mach you have with
it and just anything you want to do like
exploration setting up your workflows
all of this can be done in like with
with the subset itself and after we
have uh you're unable to log in maybe
Kim can you help Brian yeah thank
you uh like once we have a workflow
setup like you know you understand the
data set you you know what you want to
do then we can think about uh the next
step and like working with the entire
full data set so uh we will be skipping
over the uh the subset or like the
single machine part and jumping directly
to to Big Data
workflows and uh for this tutorial we
are going to be using the airline on
Time Performance data so this is a data
set um like the data is published by the
US Department of Transportation
um and we have just uh downloaded it and
put it up in uh Park format um on Google
Cloud uh the instance is also hosted on
Google Cloud so all of this is happening
Cloud uh this data set is about 70 gigs
uh on disk so this is really a big data
set which that's why we say you probably
won't be able to work with this locally
like if you want to just follow along
okay so uh starting with need for scale
um we won't be executing this section
but you can if you want to your c will
crash so you may just have to you know
restart your kernel and uh start
over but why do we need to work with
these new tools task H plot um nibari
it's because
um you cannot work with large data sets
Beyond a certain size with the
additional tools that we love which is n
p designed to be cial tools
right um and they work with data set
loaded into the Ram or like usually we
just say memory and there's only so much
memory we have so what we can do instead
is work with data that fits in memory in
small small chunks and then combine the
results and have the analysis over the
entire data
set okay so uh that's why we need scale
to you know make sense of the large make
use of the large data sets we have right
now um so with that let's start with the
first Library we look at which is dusk
um are folks familiar with dusk like
just to get a sense of uh uh room or
have you all done any kind of par
distributed work before
use task and project awesome yeah basics
of task I've used Fast spark extensively
nice okay all right so uh
okay did my audio just cut out
Kim no you're
good I it's still a little it's a little
crackly still but I don't hear you I
think I'll have to
join
back no would you mind just continuing
for a little bit and I can I can take
over okay um all right so while Petra is
figuring out her audio yeah her so her
audio uh it it was a little crackly on
and off we tried a thousand and one
different things before this uh before
we got started and this is as good as we
can get it so please be patient with us
or be patient with the the audio issues
um although I don't know why it entirely
went out hopefully she can resolve that
um um yeah so
um I wasn't prepared to present uh so um
a little bit about dask so dask is um a
python package that is used for parallel
and distributed computing in Python um
the idea behind dask is it gives us a a
an API that is familiar so it has
several layers of of um of apis uh and
the one that we're going to talk about
first and I think Ed primarily today is
the data frame API so if you're familiar
with um pandas this is uh G to feel
actually it's I believe it's identical
to the um to the pandas API the dash
data frame API is the same um also we're
not the only ones with audio issues good
um so
um so what uh Das does is it allows us
to do parallel Computing so rather than
setting up a network of parallel
Computing and having to manage the
parallelism on our own and distribute
the work amongst uh different um
computers dask handles all of that for
us behind the scenes so all we have to
do is uh transform our data calls uh
into Das data frame API calls and then
it will distribute to um the U parallel
Network we have behind the scenes on its
own all right pavitra are we good I hope
so but yeah it's nice to know we not the
only ones yes guessing this yeah uh so
yeah as Kim said like uh the whole point
of dask is yeah you don't have to learn
a whole new API but like use the API you
know fairly well and um task will handle
everything else and not just parall
Computing but also Distributing the
workload um which is my favorite part
about task you can use it on your local
machine you can use it on cloud instance
or HC um but it's still the same media
everything else is handled behind the
scenes pretty seamlessly for the most
part okay so uh in front of the theframe
API also uh like dask also has an API
that mirrors the numai API which is
called the dask array right so for all
your array workloads you can use that
and dask array um is also extended into
like I think xray uses task as well if
if you really want to do big data
geospatial
work uh but yeah we'll be focusing on
the data frame API and pandas
workloads uh so let's start by doing an
import so as you would import pspd
usually we do DD for D data frame and
read CSV again very familiar uh and
right now we starting with only uh 4
months of data
just uh to illustrate a couple of points
and then we'll move to the full data set
okay so this is just grabbing September
October November December of 2020 these
are actually only four months it's not
four months across several years it's
only four months of
2020 and uh let's look at what DDF
actually holds so this
is where um lazy evaluation will come in
but uh D actually hasn't done any
computation yet it has just grabbed some
metadata like it knows what this data
frame looks like like you know all the
column names it knows how many rows um
of data this has and like what the data
type it expects these to be right but
actually nothing has happened yet um but
we look at Lazy valuation in just a
little
bit and uh before we do that there is a
caveat with dusk which is
is yeah so we see ahead which is again
one of the first things you would do
fails with a DAT type mismatch so I said
task is you know it's kind of maybe it's
I think it's reading like one row or
something and trying to infer what data
type the entire column is which is not
always accurate and when whenever
there's a clash there will be an error
because it's trying to read the entire
column assuming the DAT type uh in
compared to something like pandas which
is going to read the entire column and
then import the data type so but that's
a luxury that D does not have because it
just can't read your entire data side in
at once right so one of the first things
to think about or like be careful with
is being explicit about the type of data
you're using in in a big data scenario
so uh to just make sure we get this
right we have already created a DAT Ty
Json file to thecorrect data types so
I'm going to import that and provide
that as a argument
here and then that should not have any
problem reading our data set and
actually getting those uh yeah first
five head
values and also all of the uh columns so
now we've actually learned how to load
the data
incorrectly now coming to L valuation
that I hinted on earlier um the whole I
guess how task this is one of the
preliminary aspects of task which is all
of your computations are set
up once and then executed at the end
hopefully
um that's what we mean by lazy it's
being lazy in evaluating your workflows
so anything we want to do here so I'm
going to do account
operation so dask
has a logic for performing this
operation but it hasn't actually done
the work yet in fact the work it has set
up can be visualized with the visualized
command and this is the work it has set
up it needs to read the data first which
it hasn't done yet uh then it will do a
count operation and it will aggregate
all of these and give you a result and
everything in the same um horizontal
layer will be executed in parallel okay
and this is what we call call a task
graph in task uh so every time we we we
discuss like task graph is one of the
key terminologies we use in the task
plan so um visualiz is showing you the
task graph and task sets up a task graph
right and then it computes a task graph
so task graph is like the Intermediate
state to enable Las valuation okay uh
what is one to six uh these are the six
chunks good question uh do I have it
here yes so um D data frame is working
in partitions and here we see 1 0 1 2 3
4 5 six these are
the two four we have seven yes so we
have seven partitions which I think
should have been visible even up here we
have n partitions equals s so uh these
are the seven actually pandas data
frames that task is going to evaluate
this on and then aggregate the result
because it can work on these pandas data
frames in memory um and it do all of
these in parallel and then uh agregate
the results does that make sense
Anon okay so to actually do the
computation we need to use the do
compute
and then we will get actually get the
result instead of this
structure uh and to elaborate this again
um a gas data frame at its score is just
a bunch of pandas data frames partition
like each partition is a pandas data
frame and almost any compute uh workflow
that we set up is going to be worked on
in these individual pandas data frames
and then combined at the end in various
ways that dask handles behind the
scenes uh and yeah there we have the
actual result uh there's a small note
here which is certain functions will do
an implicit compute so here we called a
compute to get the result right this is
where the actual work happens task will
decide the size number of partions for
us yes it will uh it will by default but
you can also set
it no I did not so that's also a good
question so uh it it will infer this in
a logical way depending on how your data
is uh is is is is stored and wherever
you're storing it like there are some
formats um that actually you can store
partitions separately uh
but yeah does does does do do this
automatically um you can use a
repartition command to do the to change
partitions as you need
to okay and to actually see the number
of partitions at any point you can use
the end
partitions all right so is this clear so
far like how dok
Works uh some data types like par
partition on saving yeah
all right and I guess uh also how it
decides on that is based
on uh a
certain like till till a certain size
right uh it can hold in one partition so
that's how each partition is decided but
I might be wrong I I'll verify
that okay so moving on uh also like in
this
particular uh uh in this particular
tutorial we're using Park so we actually
have
partitions saved in the data format
itself so so far we've talked about Dusk
and as I said dusk works both for
General parallelism so you can use what
we've done so far right like we haven't
done any distributed per se all of this
is just parallel Computing and this will
work on your laptop so it will even if
the data is stored on your laptop or on
the Cloud it willing in uh each
partition will be brought into memory
worked on uh and then aggregated so so
far things should work on your local
machine and uh to move to a cloud or
like actually distributed structure
we bring in the concept of clusters
right uh and in any distributed cluster
we have a Schuler and we'll have a few
workers so um
aular the workers are the ones that
actually will do the work like when you
do do compute they're the ones who going
to do the computation the schedular
thinks about uh and orchestrates the
work and like passes on correct
workflows to like parts of computations
to each worker and like gathers the
results and like manages all the workers
right and in task we have a client so
our client right now is the jupit lab
interface uh and the client is the
interface between like for us um like
dask and the dask cluster so client is
how uh or or python script whatever
you're using dask they are the these
client is what we interact with directly
as
users is that uh clear okay so dask has
a concept of local cluster uh which we
will not be getting into U but if you do
want to use T locally you can you know
emulate a
distributed distributed computation on a
local machine using dask local cluster
is I think also the recommended way to
use dask or local
machine okay
uh and uh to use task on a cloud system
or an HPC system we have
certain um other like
our sister projects in the dask
ecosystem so we we'll be using dask
Gateway so dask Gateway is a Library
part of the dusk um project right like
not dusk core Library but the dask
project as a whole so this lets us use
dask on in in a containerized manner and
like um D Gateway is powerful you can
use it in on cloud system but I think
also HPC systems but like there are a
lot of options if you want to deploy it
yourself nibari uses task Gateway by
default so all of our workflows with
task are going to use Gateway as
well uh everything okay so
far
yeah
awesome I can't tell who is doing the
thumbs up but it's really
appreciate so now in the notebook uh
we're making calculations on a local
machine no uh we were doing it so far
yes like till right all the computations
we did so far were being done only on
the medium instance that you started on
the cloud everything was happening
locally
there but now we will move on to a
cluster okay so to use a Gateway cluster
we will import Gateway create a Gateway
instance and set some options let's look
at what these options
are uh so here we see an environment and
cluster profile so these are options
that uh We've made visible through nepar
but there are a lot a lot lot more
options that Gateway directly exposes um
but for us we just need to make sure you
you have the right environment and right
cluster profile um so this means like
every worker that is created right all
of the other machines that your work is
going to be distributed on to to like
Leverage all the resources that the
other machines will have so your medium
instance has how much we have 16 gigs of
RAM so that that that's the amount of
data we can work with um but now when we
start five more instances with 16 gigs
of Thum we're going to use all of these
resources
together
uh what is fs. glob uh let's just come
back to that Brian maybe at the end
right uh I think that's just uh to make
sure we have the correct path together
I'm yeah I'm not sure maybe we missed
the import uh but maybe Kim can take a
look and answer
you okay so all of our uh and the
environment is important because all of
our workers also need to have the right
set of libraries to work with right um
so all of them need to have the same
like need to have task Tas theat frame
um and the right versions of Tas theat
frame to work with so this is what the
these two options
ensure all right so after selecting the
those we will actually create a cluster
with these options let's start it we
should get another handy
widget okay so here we see manual and
adaptive scaling so let's pause here and
discuss what these are in manual scaling
you can set the exact number of workers
you want to use for your task which
which works in most cases right uh if
you know that you know so many workers
are be enough and like you have a sense
of that all good but sometimes you don't
and that's where adaptive scaling is
really useful where you can set a
minimum and maximum number so uh and
number of workers will be created if
there is need for them um and this will
be handled by Gateway behind the scenes
so for for this tutorial we'll start
with five because um we've tested this
we need at least five and we will do a
maximum of 10 so uh and we actually able
to see as new workers are spun up so and
click on adapt
uh in the real world scenario you will
actually do like one to 10 because you
don't want to have you know resources
idling because all of these workers are
on the cloud they cost actual money to
keep keep up and running so uh you only
want to use them as in when you need it
for this tutorial uh just to make sure
you know you actually have these and
don't have to wait for new resources to
be allocated we'll work with five
minimum okay I have hit adapt and I'm
going to connect a client to it so
client is I'm connect my Jupiter lab to
our cluster
okay so far so
good uh I hope
everyone's there's no stalling here
sometimes like when we've had a lot of
folks access uh ask onari we we've seen
some uh slowdowns but give it a few
minutes like if you still don't see
something just let us know in the chat
and we'll we'll look into it okay okay
now comes my actually this is my my
favorite part of our task which is the
dashboard
um so uh you see a dashboard link here
right uh I for the first time you use
this this is a nebari specific thing
where you need to log in to make sure
you can access the dashboard so uh go
ahead and click
this uh this is opening the UI for me
but you may see another um like sign in
option like when you when you log into
NE for the first time you should have
used you saw a key clo sign in you may
see that um so just use your
username which is _ whichever number you
chose and the password you
selected once you do that you should
have this dashboard
open and this this should be a onetime
thing um we don't need to continue doing
that okay so uh just make sure this
works but this is one way to access the
dashboard right in a new browser window
but we can also access it within J Lab
so the 1 2 3 fourth icon in the leftmost
sidebar is what is nibari awesome
question I will get to that in just a
bit let's let's complete the last
section and then we'll answer
that okay we're also already 30 minutes
in so I'll speed up a little
bit uh this is the dask Jupiter lab
extension it took mine some minutes to
new cluster yeah that's what I was
hoping yeah
okay and click on this um magnifying
glass icon so this is going to grab the
dashboard link from your active jbit lab
window and populate a list of plots so
these are diagnostic plots so why are
these actually important and why is this
so
powerful uh in a distributed setup when
your work is happening on several
machines it's really tricky to keep
track of what is going on right uh if it
was on your local machine you can look
at like activity monitor like on a Mac
or like equalent once on other machines
and see what's happening um but when you
have like running on 10 or 100 different
machines you need a also like you you
it's very hard to make sense of logs
even at that scale so you need a
different way to understand what's going
on and that's what these graphs provide
so these are plots about your
computation okay so uh we're going to
open a few cool ones let's open the
cluster map this is in alphabetical
order um just if you are having trouble
finding things so cluster
map uh
progress and then task
stream and let's open the workers memory
what is it this one uh because this is J
Lab you can also move these around and
fit them on your screen in a way you
like let's go t stream
here I need a progress on the side and
recur
memory okay uh does everyone have the
plot set
up let's work through these plots one by
one um so the cluster map is showing us
visualization of the schedular in
between in purple and all of our workers
are around it in
this yellow orer orange
color uh and right now if you remember
we did minimum five workers and maximum
10 because we requested five workers
minimum we have five workers here and as
your
workflows uh you missed what to do in
the dashboard okay uh just one second
Ross I'll get back to you so as more as
as more workers are requested you'll see
them show up here
okay I've got the orange dots so the the
workers I've got no orange dots uh that
means um there is just you you may need
to wait a little bit Arena to start
getting workers but uh that's why we
requested five minimum you'll slowly get
the first five uh
workers okay so how do you open the
dashboard again so um first off click on
the dashboard link to make sure you're
actually logged
in right so click on the uh in the
client widget that we have this is in
the manual versus adaptive and D gateway
gateway cluster
section uh if you click on that you
should get an option to sign in Just For
the First Time uh sign in with your
username and password to just access the
dashboard on nari and then uh click on
the uh dusk icon in the very left
sidebar here it's the fourth icon from
the
top uh you should be able to C the
magnifying glass icon which will uh grab
the link for
you and then uh just click on one of
these tiles to open the corresponding
plot and the plot you need is
listed uh in here itself
yeah I don't see the icons on the
left uh you may not need to log in like
that's a it it this is yeah I'm not sure
may
maybe you only need log in the first
time and it's a little flaky uh
sometimes you need to sometimes it uh
grabs your au indication information I
open dashboard and the link and it's
empty yeah it it will
be you may not see oh interesting
uh you may to click enter after the link
is populated yeah that may also be the
case so uh the link here is basically
the same link as your as as the link
displayed here for the
dashboard and after you if you paste
that that link into the jupyter lab
widget on the left there at the top um
you have to press enter or it won't
populate those orange
tiles yeah if it's not connected maybe
you need to log in is my guess uh and if
you don't see any uh workers because the
workers haven't been allocated to you
just wait a little bit uh you should get
Workers had to paste the URL okay yeah
that's the other
option
uh all right so let's move on and I'll
just let us know in the chat if more
folks have issues that was the cluster
map and the we discuss these you know as
we do computations then
okay so uh let's start with uh basic
computation let's not do this as an
exercise but just do it together so we
are calculating the longest flight
distance in our data set
and because we have a do compute the
actual workflow is Computing and like
only when it computes will you see
activity in our in the diagnostic plots
okay
um
and yeah we'll discuss the plots as we
do more more
computations and yeah maybe saw there
was another worker created and then
remove because it wasn't needed okay uh
let's end this intro toask section with
a disclaimer if just always remember to
close your cluster right um these are I
said actual machines taking up actual
money and resources so if you don't shut
these down and if they are not handled
in a different way uh in your system
like yeah you're going to incur a lot of
costs so for dask you can shut down the
class with cluster or shut down and
additional optional step is also to do a
client. close the connection from your
um lab interface to the cluster you're
closing that okay so that's the
insection complete any questions so far
is Clear yeah awesome uh we had a
question about what is nibari uh so
nibari is a data science platform under
the hood it is a uh opinionated Jupiter
Hub distribution do folks know what
Jupiter Hub is here um if you if this
the first time you're hearing it hearing
about it Jupiter Hub is a Jupiter
project uh is is a part of the Jor
project uh ecosystem the J ecosystem uh
and designed to allow more folks uh to
use St notebooks collaboratively so it
it provides uh ways to have shared
compute uh and shared
environments and what nari does is it
gives you a quick way to deploy your own
Jupiter Hub with like same defaults
right so it has task built in it has
environment management built in so
that's what nibari is and we have used
neali to set up this platform for you
yeah thank you Kim if you have any
questions we can also discuss that at
the very end of the tutorial
okay uh the graph will be uh
empty for two reasons like either you
don't have workers and computer is
actually not happening
um and it's going to be empty like uh
until we do an actual computation like
with do
compute
okay
uh if there are no other major questions
let's move on to more task computations
so I would suggest most folks here shut
down and try to restart your cluster I
am going to continue with the same
cluster just because I'm presenting and
I don't want to wait for more resources
okay
so now we are in uh number two you can
you can access this through the uh file
navigation panel
here
okay uh you want to go over how you how
you get the panes on the
right uh you mean settings up oh yeah so
uh you can
just uh click on the name here or like
the uh
tab head heading yeah I think if you
could go over um clicking on the dask
Jupiter lab extension button
yeah uh let's open a new one let's go
with uh so we get those by clicking on
those um orange buttons yeah they should
open up automatically in your active
window and then you can arrange it as
you
want the cluster map has only one Circle
it's because uh you haven't been
allocated uh workers yet from
gcp uh all right so uh we used a manual
approach right to create your cluster
you can also do it programmatically um
using this code section which I let you
all run um I'm going to connect to an
already running cluster with with these
lines of codes which which you'll also
do in the next notebook so this is not
something you're missing out
on oh I have to import task
though and let's do
this I'm going
to yeah all right so I'm connected to
the same cluster and let me also get
back a client
awesome uh so this client object is what
as I said like lets us connect to the
cluster and like Al you don't see it
being used directly like when you do a
uh d. compute right like the client
object is being used to connect to the
classroom okay so let's again read back
our data set this time let's read the
full data
set not just for
months um and I did mention briefly that
uh
some functions like head do an implicit
compute like behind the scenes and
that's why you saw some activity
happening
here so uh okay getting back to the
tutorial and like just the Practical
aspect of the tutorial we won't go
through like a step by step in to dask
and how to work with it right we're
going to look at just the things you
need to be aware of by working with Dusk
and this this notebook is structured in
like a let's let's talk about the best
practices and cover task like in in that
way so the first things is uh
shuffling in what we mean by shuffling
let's actually see it with an example oh
no my image is not visible okay let's
let this run I will take an opportunity
to uh explain the plots while this runs
actually because this is going to take
at least about five minutes to
complete um so our data if it is not
um there are some computations like for
instance when you do a sort right or if
you do like setting the index which
needs a sort uh or or any other function
like which if you need to think of it
like uh think of an average versus how
would you how would you calculate an
average versus calculating a median in a
distributed system where you're only
working with like chunks of data average
you can do like average of each and then
uh sorry like sum of each each and then
do an average together but like for
median you will need to sort this entire
data set which is actually as uh small
small
partitions and then take the middle
value right so one is a lot more
different than the other and like a
median operation will involve a lot of
like data transfer between partitions
right so that is what we mean by
shuffling shuffling is anywhere you need
this data transfer between partitions
and like a lot of it is required and and
in a distributed setup we kind of want
to minimize shuffling because data
transfer is the most expensive thing you
will do in a distributed workflow so in
this section in fact the first or our
default data set the full data set we
downloaded here is not sorted and uh
you'll see it it takes forever to and
once the plot loads the plot will look
really really wonky um so what we the
best practice here is generally when you
data sets try to do a sort once right
before you even start your actual uh you
want to make sure you you store the
sorted data set and you're working on
that from the beginning so that's what
we do here uh starting this cell and
moving on for the rest of the tutorial
we'll be using a sorted data
set yeah I will let this
complete
bit and uh here let's do like a side and
talk about the plots again while the
computation runs okay so uh let's go to
the task stream
now so this is literally what is being
executed
on the cluster being visualized in a
single uh
clot fact let's look at it a little
closely so each of these just if you
hover on them these are all V plot
they're all interactive plots you can
hover on them to see what was being
executed and I believe all of these are
um like toal number of threads right on
all the
machines so each is like one horizontal
line and uh the green is like successful
good compute and red is all the uh data
transfer so the more red you have uh the
less efficient your distributed compute
is so uh progress is like so the task
scam like a a worker based view or like
a thread based view of what's going on
progress is like what is actually
happening um so this task which has
almost one to 51 subtasks right um is
progressing slowly so all of these will
happen in the distributor you should see
the all of the all of the colors are
connected so um in the task stream
you'll have series Group
by I can't see the whole yeah or like
yellow is he by count combin so that
will be the same in the task stream as
well so you're seeing the task based
view here and how it's
progressing the more red I see the more
skew uh I don't know what you mean by
skew
Nishan I would say there's just a lot
more uh data transfer happening that's
also what you see as red lines here like
in the cluster map like the red dotted
lines are also inter worker
communication
yeah so as these tasks progress so do
the uh task streams and uh workers
memory is fairly self I mean it's it's
as the name suggests it's how much
memory is being used uh per
worker right now we have 10 workers like
and you see all of them
here
right uh I will actually let this task
complete the first one I I will stop the
next
one but uh you all can have it uh
by
uh all right I think I see we also at
like almost 50 minutes so how about we
also take a like two three minute break
I drink some water and this computation
compl let's do
that I'm here to answer any questions
though like if you have but like I want
to continue with the tutorial section
you can also go grab some water if you
want and we'll start back in like couple
of minutes like
uh oh time zones oh uh so in about two
to four minutes
okay
any questions though and also like have
folks caught up have you all
received
workers
I hope
so by account cell is running
awesome
Did you sort the data set by FL date of
yeah I believe that's the
one is that it though uh let me just
check the I kind kind of don't remember
it's yeah we this way back
when uh I would think so
yes I I'm not sure though uh I will how
about I take a look at the very end
right me me if you have question if you
have time I can then answer you or I'll
let you know on the
card I just look I need to look up the
scripts and see what we sorted it by
like it is definitely date I don't know
if we like combine the uh year quarter
month or if we use the flo
date but it's definitely sorted by like
U overall date
though there's also some like um it's
going pretty fast on my end but I can
see the stream is a little slow so there
is also like I'm screen sharing and it's
getting to use that's also why this may
look a little slower um this it should
be much faster on your on your old
instance sorting
mechanism yeah made a
note or maybe Kim if you can look up I
think there's a script in our uh in the
complete tutorial um we can see what how
we sorted
this
all right so uh let's just yeah
gradually jump back into the
tutorial I hope this compute complete
soon enough right let me give myself
more space
here so this is the unsorted data set
and you can see the plot is all over
because it's not in the correct uh order
that's also why we had like almost over
a thousand
tasks um in know the sorted SK set
because we don't have to do the sort
again we have much fewer items um and
like once the plot shows up you'll also
see it's like that's the plot you expect
when you do uh a group
account
okay let's start discussing the next
couple of Concepts uh as this
computation completes so uh persisting
so persisting
is the CM the overall progress is just
the combination all of all progress bars
yeah that's correct yeah across all uh
workers um okay uh a single bar for all
progress there yeah I don't think
there's one in the uh our diagnostic
plots
though sorry but distracted by the chat
uh coming back to persistent data sets
and intermediate values
so uh here so far what we've done is we
have data on the cloud so all of our
data is actually stored on Google Cloud
right uh we are doing some Compu here D
this is a Compu I want to execute Das
does like like creates the logic we do
compute uh do then goes in and tries to
execute this also like by uh reading the
dat performing the compute and then
giving us the final result in our local
client
now uh this works
fine sometimes just to things up if you
want to use the same data or like the
same uh intermediate values for multiple
executions right and if you want if
you're actually thinking of doing a
compute so many times uh it's going to
take a while so what you can do instead
is persist data uh your certain like
intermediate work or a portion of your
data set so what persist does
is it's going to store that in the like
on the workers itself
so I think we we'll do a process right
after this computes and you'll see the
uh like that the workers have some
memory uh reserved and you'll see a
certain amount
of uh we will see it in the in the graph
itself and like it's very clear that
this is beinged on the workers and not
being read in each time okay so this
will make things a little faster because
your data doesn't need to be fetched and
push to the workers each time but it's
already there
um and this also helps with data
locality okay it is like
anality is a a combined or like it's a
part of persisting in a way where DK
will try to
assign work or like assign tasks like
the schedular CR to assign tasks to
workers based on the kind of data it has
locally so that's handled by D behind
the scenes that's what dity means um so
that way that your the data does need to
move between uh workers and we like
reduce overall the data transfer costs
here all right uh just waiting for
this Tas to to
complete so uh this is why um this is
taking so long I'll actually uh give a
little bit of side note here because we
are plotting the data set and we'll
discuss history plot in the next
notebook where we'll actually use this
on a much smaller data set and not the
full complete data set because plotting
requires an additional set
of um computations it's not just doing
the computer and plotting it directly so
that's why this takes so long on the
complete data set um but the actual only
if you if you don't plot and do just the
computation um the five to 10 uh workers
that we've assigned should be should be
enough the the next computes will be
pretty pretty fast okay compared to this
one all
right uh so this is the it's over and
this plot looks a lot like what you
would expect from a group account okay
now let's move on and the
faster and fun
bits uh so want to understand like
persisting we will do actually let's
open up another plot which is the graph
where's the graph this
one yeah so this is the um distributed
task graph right
in uh in the uh diagnostic plots so let
me right now there is nothing here the
schedular isn't doing anything we
haven't set up anything to be
computed so that's why this is empty but
when we do persist something we'll see
stuff there that's why I want to start
that's I want to have it here um we are
going to compute the number of departure
and arrival delays per day so we are
doing two different things um departure
and um looking at two different uh
columns in our dat set departure and
arrival but we are grouping them both by
uh dat for so there is like a little bit
of uh a part of this operation is same
for both of these different
computes let's do these one by one and
see how long it takes so this is
bcph work has been cued
right uh we got more workers and they've
started Computing
this
once these complete we will persist a
portion of our data so also to remember
here is we don't want to persist the
entire data set because our workers will
land on out of like you don't want to be
persisting 70 GB like we don't have that
much like actually Dam or working space
uh no task here just one second I'll get
Christopher so um we don't have that
much space so we want to persist the
data will be using here here we using
departure delay arrival delay
and flight date these are the three
columns and we'll we'll persist only
those three colums uh once the first
part of this
completes now to your question um just
the graphics sold me I can look at this
I know I know as I said this is my
favorite part of Tas as
well looks like able to follow along
like get the same part a little little
behind ahead is this space okay too slow
too fast I see the are I think we should
make
time fairly
well uh is everything clear like just um
let me know there any issues like
hearing me understanding me all of
that okay I see for a c more just that I
know that youall have all CAU up to
where I'm at and then we can
continue uh our first computer is done
so
our departure delay is done now we're
doing arrival delay this took about uh 1
minute 30 seconds so I'm also like
screen
sharing yeah to the
gra should the graph on the second data
set be slow what do we mean by the
second data
set sorry uh sorted data set I didn't
read sorry
uh it should be faster like when you
plot this when you plot like the HP plot
on the second one the sorted one it
should be faster is the number of tasks
equal to number of partitions no
uh
so
tasks are the total so we have a set of
operations that need to on each
data frame right like so let's do a very
simple like average or actually let's do
a sum the very basic operation we could
do like you know and so what what we'll
do is do sum in each partition right uh
follow we'll do it and then we'll add
all of the sums and then provide the
result so if we had five partions so our
initial sum we have five tasks then
doing like adding all of these together
is another one um so we'll have in total
six so like depending on the complexity
of your workflow number of tasks is
going to differ but I but like of course
the more partitions you have the more
tasks you'll have but it's not a direct
relation does that make
sense that's true uh thanks Kim number
of workers will affect the speed at
which a compute
happens okay we have we have we have
times this took about both of these took
about like over 1 minute 30 seconds now
we will persist a portion of our
data and uh the important thing to note
here is when you do a compute you get
the final result right like when I did a
compute here I got the final result like
with the answers like and uh sometimes
in the compute you got like a single
number like this is the final final
answer but a persist operation is going
to give back the um reference right so
here we are processing a data frame so
we getting the same structure of a data
frame to work with that's an important
like caveat when you persist
things now let's do the same confute
again um
I did okay yeah yeah that was a lot
quicker and you can see here uh all of
our the subset of our data is stored in
memory and like there's some even though
there's no compute happening there's
some extra memory being used on certain
workers and uh uh and our task graph
also shows that that is memory being
used okay so that's what persisting is
and I did say you can use intermediate
results um
so if I we don't have it here but um we
can do like a client. compute and have
like two different uh things within it
like um like a comma B so if a and b are
two different like computations they can
share certain internal um if if there is
like a shared section of the task graph
like the set of executions certain
results can be shared between them to
make it faster as well but you can learn
more about that in the D
documentation we won't we covering that
today okay so uh the next like best
practice around this so first we looked
at reducing shuffling uh second we
looked at persisting when necessary and
only persisting what is necessary right
uh third is partitions so the number of
partitions you have is important this
get this gets really important in Array
workloads right because usually you have
really large arrays and the way you
chunk just plays a tremendous role in uh
the performance you get uh so in the
data frame land uh we we call these
partitions in Array land these will be
called chunks usually so uh if you have
too many partitions like if you have
like a thousand partitions uh and only
uh and like way to many workers or
whatever like your schedule becomes
really really bottl right because it's
it's now having to um the number of
tasks will increase based on number of
partitions as I said not linearly but
like obviously like more partitions you
have the more tasks you have so our schu
is like becoming really overworked so we
want to avoid that just for efficiency
right but also we don't want too few
partitions so u a partition like a
partition as a whole is being sent to a
worker so I have five workers but if I
only had two partitions um ideally like
rather only two workers here will be
used and the other three are idling so
we want to choose number of partitions
uh
effectively and how do you do that a
little bit of trial and error I guess
but also these plots will help you so if
you see like the work memory just
skyrocketing you know that you need more
workers um and with more workers you
want to like correlate and have more
partitions
okay uh also this depends a little bit
on the type of task as well right some
tasks are a lot more paraliz like like
we had an example of mean versus median
so mean is like a lot more paralyzable
than a median so if if you're if of all
of your computations have a very non-
shuffling like like rather minimal
shuffling
uh workflow like that that's the kind of
workflows you have uh you can get away
with more partitions there as well so
there's a little bit of nuance but it's
another like thing you want to consider
when you do uh distributed
compute uh it
depends on the
resources I know not okay the question
here is what is the optimal number of
partitions or the optimal partition size
as Kim said it depends on your number of
like your workers your comp compute
there is uh
it's there are a lot of cool block posts
about this so yeah all right so let's
move
on let's move on
to uh oh yeah so like to two change
partitions you can use the uh
repartition method
okay so we have a couple of exercises
for y'all I
will I will run the
solutions and uh you don't have to you
can take a pass of this yourself as well
so uh now we are going to actually you
know what uh we
have we have 50
minutes this is quite similar to what we
had earlier we're doing a repartition
and then another compute so I will
actually skip over this U but I'll let
you all take a look
okay uh okay this is the
final piece we've discussing about
distributed compute and this is actually
very darkk specific this is not broadly
applicable to distributed compute from
what I can tell uh which is the meta
keyword so as we discussed earlier every
time you you set up a computation like
before you actually do the dot compute
right when you create the task gra dask
is making a educated guess about the
kind of output at at each stage so when
I do a group by and I do a compute sorry
a account or group by and apply
something uh uh applying a
function task is making a guess about
what what the output of a group by will
look like uh change with you know the
output of a Compu like account is going
to give me a number at the end so it's
going to make a guess and think and like
design the task graph that way but
sometimes when you don't
use uh when like when this chain becomes
too long or when you don't use
um uh said or like functions that task
understands like for
example this question where we have a
custom like Lambda function which D
doeses not understand what should it do
and like that's where it will throw
a warning
saying uh specify the meta keyword So
Meta is how you can tell dask what kind
of output to expect at the end of this
uh compute so
here this is most relevant usually when
we use apply because that's where a lot
of custom functions come in okay
so to use it what you can do is create
a
sample uh like empty data frame because
at the end of this I expect to get one
like get a sorry a panda Series so the
output is going to be a series right so
and pass that to meta at the end of this
task knows this is the kind of output I
should expect and can run this
computation in a more like reliable
manner so if I do this I shouldn't have
any oh I didn't import pandas no mind I
shouldn't have any major errors
but that should
be I should be
helpful okay any questions here all
good
all
right so uh usually even without
specifying it like in some cases Tas can
make it makes the right guess uh but
it's usually just best practice to
always yes specify so just for
reliability
right okay so with that we've come to
the end of the task section of this like
just generally analyzing your data sets
in uh in in parallel after this we'll
move on
to uh
visualization
all right um here actually I
did I did comment out the the cluster
and client sh down section for everybody
so just that you also get a chance
to uh continue with the same cluster
because like this is one of the most uh
time consuming bits and work in the
cloud H I messed up
my oops
give me a second while I get this get
this
sorted uh yeah we don't need the graph
anymore let's just use the memory plot
okay yeah so uh yeah most of you
shouldn't shouldn't have shut down their
clusters after the previous notebook and
can just continue using that if you
reconnect to the cluster section in the
third note
book just maybe give me a thumbs up if
everyone's done with with the previous
one because this is the next section and
we kind of Shifting Gears a
lot
okay
uh let's do the same uh I also connect
to my cluster here and get a
CL all
right so uh now for the visualization
section here's where we actually going
to
use H
plot uh we will work with a we will work
with only like a subset of our data set
because even with this cluster um
visualizing things takes up a lot of
confute behind the
scenes okay we have a few different
comments
actually yeah uh that that's kind of why
I let me wait for a couple more couple
more minutes right like while folks
catch up I rather
not I I don't want you all to do
multitasking um so yeah let's complete
and like shift gears to
visualizing so now all of the
distribution is going to happen behind
the scenes right if you actually want to
you can just close all of the plots uh
I'll just leave them on uh let's let's
just leave one plot on actually um we
don't need any of these anymore this one
just to make sure like our this is just
easier way to see that more workers are
coming on like or if some of my workers
died I'll know immediately but there
there are other plots that give you this
information as well I know yeah such
great Pok
stuff okay uh all right I
guess I will ask folks if you haven't
already let's move on to the third
notebook we have
about 40 minutes so let's let's cover
this and uh that way we'll have some
time for questions at the end I think
I'm going to have a lot of questions
okay so uh visualization and Big Data
visualization in specific uh we have a
lot of visualization tools in
the B ecosystem right and all of them
have their own special purposes for this
tutorial and especially um I guess our
te right this is a lot more familiar
with the hollow Wiz toolkit so Hollow
Wiz is a set of tools which includes H
plot but also panel Hol views data
Shader like a bunch of interactive
visualization tools that are like really
powerful built for specific use cases so
each VI plot what using today is you can
think of it as a interactive replacement
for the do plot API that we have in
pandas this is a
very in our opinion a very like friendly
way to get into the interactive
visualization landscape and like it it
also just provides a lot of nice default
options for us that's how they using H
plot but if you're really curious and
honestly this is actually quite fun uh I
would fully encourage you to go through
uh and check out like call views your
panel separately because they're all
really powerful and awesome okay so uh
as this like visualization like this
diagram suggests HP plot is like a
wrapper around or like provides the same
interface as thought plot in Bas and it
works with a lot of different data types
so you can actually use HP plot with
pandas directly but because we've been
using D so far and D data frame it also
plugs in just equally well with dask but
also all of these other options like
x-ray grating some
water uh and behind the scenes this uses
Hall of views Hall of views is like
directly a layer over Bou like um Bou is
an interactive visualization Library a
more fundamental Library um that is
built like for the web and Hollow of VI
is like a layer on top H plot uses
Hollow of use uh and data Shader which
we look actually look at data Shader
again at the very end here but data
Shader is for actually really big data
computes in a visualization but we will
get to in a
bit and Hollow actually works with and
plotly as well if you want to use it
separately okay but today we using H
plot uh okay so let's go ahead and uh
just use a subset of our full data set
so using only a certain number of
columns and filtering the year um we're
only going to be using 20 21
onwards uh folks are not familiar with
Park this is a feature of par it's a
columnar data format so that data is
stored in a columnar format so we can do
things like filtering so we we only read
certain parts of our full data set and
we can control that
programmatically uh
mishan can we use the hollow framework
to view data frames Yes actually we're
going to do that just now right now all
right so uh out of like first off like
the flight flights is where we going to
store our data set like we've only used
data from 2021 right and we are creating
another subset where we just uh
narrowing this down to a few
carriers uh this is just to make sure uh
we get the plots quickly okay so our
even with this filtering we have quite a
few million RS to work
with uh so first off like we did this so
that we can persist this and uh as you
know we persist a small amount of data
that we actually need for computation
and persisting will let us just access
these pretty quickly and the compute
will be behind the scenes handled in a
way that is efficient with like data
locality
okay uh so to use HP plot with task we
will import HP plot. task and we'll
enable an extension so we can be using
Boke do that so make sure this cell is
executed just because of how the lab and
which we plot and poke all work
together oh thanks skim uh you meant how
the to see the data frame itself yes uh
Kim has shared tab
yeah so if you want to see actually the
table itself like the data in a more
interactive manner yes you can do that
with Hollows and calculator is the one I
thought you meant like plotting get
interactiv
sorry okay so uh let's do a quick plot
so we
will uh this is the same confute we did
in the previous notebook where we pl a
departure delay per day right
and let's do it so instead of like plot
in pandas we do H3 plot and because we
are using H plots task
um in HD plot for task data frames uh it
will do the compute behind the things
for us in the right way for this okay
let us
compute there we go that was a lot
quicker and
um we'll take a moment to actually go
through this for folks who are not
familiar with uh Boke plot so by default
you have certain uh tools right like
first off there is these are like HP
plot has given us some defaults on top
of V plot so we have a hover tool tip
you can hover on the plot and see
details about that data point you can
zoom in if you want with the uh box Zoom
right uh there is wheel Zoom just go
ahead and like explore these because
you'll end up using them for the rest of
this notebook uh you can save this plot
directly with save and just to reset
this to the base version you can click
on
reset okay
so this is an exercise for you
to write up another compute for
visualizing the we
distribution um do a mean on like any
variable in that data set you can see
the list of columns here and do a HP
plot let's see what we
have we did arrival delay again pretty
similar to our previous
one and uh an additional thing you
notice here is do scatter so this is H3
plot syntax um so do scatter is telling
HD plot so by default we had a line plot
here uh it's telling HD plot to use a
scatter plot instead we have scatter and
you can look at the H plot Gallery link
here um we have a lot of different plot
options so depending on how you want to
visualize things in like uh your actual
computation you can choose different
plots
here
okay so that was just a basic plot right
but
to make more of
interactivity uh we can also have
widgets what is a
widget let me
actually press
compute so which is any additional thing
you have
in as a part of your overall
visualization that adds more
interactivity it can be a drop down to
select certain things it can be uh it
can be like um a video buttons it can be
text input like you want to change what
is displayed in the title for example so
like these additional elements of your
overall visualizations are what we call
widgets at least in the hardest space
and H plot kind of uses like has H plot
because it's a wrapper around a lot of
other things um it has a it it creates
the right widgets for your compute
visualization so here we did a
uh here we had we we we we plotted a
histogram and we did Group by op carrier
and like we have we've only selected
four right so all of those are available
as a drop down for us
here and this is handled by HP plot we
all we had to do is call HP
plot uh and this remains interactive and
uh the cool thing it does actually for
this one let me open up the task
stream because
um if I change the
carrier it's going
to do a compute behind the scenes and
give you the new
result o in a very large answer will
change the sampling when it zooms in and
out so that's where data comes in
actually um by default it won't if you
use all H plot directly this the plot
itself is not going to trigger any
compute behind the scenes right like if
I do a zoom here you'll see nothing is
happening on the task plots uh but when
we go to data Shader that's what that's
kind of what data Shader was to do was
to visualize these really really large
volumes of data and be able to sample
these in a more interactive way so like
there when we do a zoom it'll trigger
compute and like give you a more grer
view of things
okay so um so far all
here so quick widgets is basically HP
plot handling certain widgets for you
okay the next cool thing about HP plot
is the ability to
quickly compose plots so uh let
us set up a couple of
computations we are going to group by
day of week and the carrier and plot the
departure delay uh and compute the
minimum mean and maximum departure
delays here together and let's persist
this data this plotted data Sor this
computed
data
uh next we are creating two different
plots first is an area
plot right here we are plotting uh
minimum maximum values as an
area and second is a scatter plot of the
uh mean departure delay okay so so we
have a minmax plot and we have a mean
plot let's cute this
uh that's the mean
plot sorry the minmax plot and another
mean so uh com composing is just putting
these side by side together in a single
uh panel
so if we actually reduce this uh you can
see these two are position side by side
and share interaction
elements and overlay is plotting these
on top of each other so that's where you
can use the uh star Shand for composing
we use the plus
Shand so this can be really powerful
this is actually kind of tricky or like
you will need a lot more code to uh like
put this in we call this I a layout
right like your especially the top one
this is like a row layout you're
positioning plots in the layout but e
plot makes it really really easy to put
these
together uh so now yeah these two are
combined
and can be used
together all
right there have questions so for a
Booky plot output cell if I the cell
typee as a slide
type
uh in
reacts I think that should work because
once the plot is available it's just
yeah I haven't tried that I I think it
should work though let us know if you if
you like have it handy right
now or we can try it at the very end if
you remind us okay so uh those were like
the highlights of HP plot so we've like
picked items to discuss like because for
the most part the power comes from like
actually following the do plot API right
of uh of binders so we want to keep
doing that computer over and over again
so these are the other cool things you
can do with HD plot uh
but next let's move on to Explorer so
this is almost a an a side but like not
quite um this is going to be most
helpful actually when you work with
pandas data frames so that's kind of why
we've actually done a compute and a
compute on a d data frame is going to
give you a pandas data frame okay so uh
let's do
that and Explorer I actually don't want
to explain it I want to load up if we
can while this happens fail free to like
go through the previous on there's a lot
of interaction to play around with in
the meantime
Explorer is a like a graphical tool it's
very hard to explain without seeing
honestly uh for you to to just make
sense of and like uh see what are the
interesting ways you can uh interesting
things you can infer from your data set
so you do you call Explorer on your
entire data set right and it creates it
gives you this um dashboard word like
view where you can
select um the type of plot X and Y axis
uh
any uh if you want to group group it by
something uh what kind of operations you
want PL style and let's change a few
things shall we like just for let's
change this
to scatter oh no sorry uh let's do the
scatter not everything will work um
because of course you will careful about
what we are
plotting X can be your uh Y axis let's
do okay no let's do something we've
actually done depart delay that's what
we've been plotting so far I know a lot
of folks might already be bored of it uh
let's do it by op carrier that's what we
did previously as
well and uh you want to do something
else I don't think so anyway so we have
a plot right and we can get the code to
create this plot where they should so
it's like an interactive way for you to
explore as the name suggest your dat Set
uh it is just fun ni thing that R PL
provides which can be actually quite
useful but again use this with a Pand
data frame like this can get if you use
it with like a full data set it can be
really slow and tricky to work with so
this is something you want to use for
exploration uh alone
yeah
okay
um to let you all play with that some
more there is
a there is a joy turn and exercise here
where you can use the Explorer to plot
side cancellations for day so and then
you can like generate the code and then
use that code to actually get the uh
plot
again and to save your Explorer generat
plot it also provides a do save fun
so you can use
that yeah that so Explorer will crash if
you try to do too much at
once because it's it's actually that's
kind of why we we computed and only use
the frame that fits in memory
here
okay I won't go through that I'll let y
all take care of
it um next so all of our basic plotting
is done right uh now let's move on to
some Geographic
plots uh we'll get back to where we have
25 minutes left so I'll just try to like
complete this uh wrap it up and then go
through all the questions at the end
together so Geographic plots
uh we don't have any Geo data in our
data set directly so what we've done is
uh have we we downloaded a new one uh a
new data set which has the latitude
longitude values for US airports so
that's available on GitHub there so
let's just download that and merge it
with our existing flights
data
okay not the fly fa set but like
creating an airport delayers uh data
frame which does a group
by uh departure delay based on airports
so we're going to see on a graph uh
where these where these lie like sorry
on a map where these lie sorry okay uh
let's persist the airport delays because
now that's the data frame we end up
using okay so now now Airport has our
Geographic data so lat long values for
US airports and these are um we've
looked at we are plotting the mean
departure delay for each origin airport
okay just putting this together now
let's look at what are complete like
what the data data set we're working
with is that's that's that and now we
will use HD plot. points so points is
another like uh glyph so uh we have
scatter like uh circular small gphs we
have so points does that uh and we're
going to use Goo equals true to use
Geographic data and behind the scenes
this uses Geo which is another Hollow
Wiz ecosystem tool kit which is designed
for
more uh Geographic first like Geographic
plotting
okay I
will go ahead it and execute
this oh what happened here I think it's
just naming that I might have messed up
latitude and longitude weren't
found it's
the okay I'm doing
index uh it's we have uh X and Y as
separate veres that's okay let's
do uh longitude X in latitude X let's
plot uh x value so when I did a merge
um this is the task data frame merge
right yeah so we didn't get into this a
little too much but uh merging you can
there are a lot of ways you can do
merges uh and merging in D data frame
it's you can read about it in the in the
documentation and the way Das candles
merges that's kind of why we got into
this okay I will yeah there you go that
it now I want to zoom in a little
bit and uh I should also be able to
hover and see what the departure delay
was and uh
the we have a color bar here to indicate
uh and give us a more realistic VI of
like if you want to see something in
particular
uh any questions
here
good okay um so to be clear like these
last two sections we are not going to go
into too much details like this is just
to show the because H plot is a part of
the hollow ecosystem like there is a lot
of powerful tools we can leverage
through HD plot but also use those
directly okay uh lastly uh data Shader
so I will actually just execute these
pretty
quickly uh we discussed this a little
bit earlier right so
our so far whenever we've done or looked
at uh data like the plot itself is uh
is is client there is no extra compute
happening to give us anything special
like when we zoom in it's it's literally
just zooming in in the plot itself uh
but when we actually plot like so these
points are fine but when we have too
many this going to get super congested
and all you will see is like a gradient
of blue so there when you zoom in you
want more
granular information but we don't that
that information isn't preserved right
because uh we are also working
distributedly and like to see that
information you will need like all of
your data to be computed together in a
place which we can't do so what data
Shad lets you do is it leverages like
task behind the scenes but when you zoom
in like you can then tra compute to see
a more view of Parts here so we will see
that in just a
bit uh Kim do you want some you want to
add something in this section I know
you've worked a lot more with uh
visualizations um
especially I I did I wasn't listening so
I don't know
exactly I mean I was just asking like
you want to something about uh data
Shader
ands um well I data Shader is is really
awesome because you can plot so much um
here in the browser so so what it's
doing is it's
aggregating um the data in the back end
so on the on the python side of thing
it's it's running the aggregation so
that uh what's coming to our
visualization is a down down sample data
set so we can down sample in a lot of
different ways um but we're not
losing uh the knowledge so we can see
the darker the darker colors in this
plot here indicate that we have more
data points down there uh near the zero
right um but we don't have to actually
see every individual
Point um because data Shader is kind of
handling that for us in the background
and then the beauty of HV plot is that
all we had to do was throw a data shade
equals true and it's doing all this for
us in the background without without us
having to specify anything you know
yeah like uh even when we do this
locally like the browser is going to
crash if you try to visualize like such
a large data set like forget local
machine right so uh yeah this became a
little more clearer because once I
zoomed in it's going to retrigger
compute to show us that but when you
look at the overall view everything is
super down sampled as Kim
suggested so I think with that we've
come to the end of our
tutorial um there are a few more
sections if you would like to uh take a
look um just a few options that you can
use with data Shader we won't go into
these
super in detail but yeah okay any other
questions like okay now is your time to
ask all the questions
actually
um so I will like at this caveat like we
to give like a very condensed view of
you know what these tools especially the
part of these tools but also generally
how to think about things in Big Data
World um so uh to use these in your
dayto day you'll like you'll have to go
in and refer to the documentation and
understand the nuances of these
tools don't forget to shut down your
clusters should have said that before I
said the tutorial is over at the end to
make sure yeah all the resources are
actually uh shut down
gracefully when you do that like your
plot should disappear you you shouldn't
have anything available here
so uh do folks have questions general
questions about what we discussed about
the platform
about anything what's your recommended
strategy to committing these interactive
notebooks do Version Control other than
just removing the interactive Parts is
there a middle round I don't think you
can currently commit at least um okay I
am only I'll add this I'm only familiar
with okay based plots uh I don't know
about uh flly or uh or mtb's interactive
elements but with Boke I you cannot
currently commit these
to like HTML version will be saved right
like at the end of the day the
interactions are handled through HTML
um
I yeah I I think you're going to be
losing a little
bit you will have to rec compute to get
like the actual accurate value uh for
basic plots I think if it's just like
JavaScript side like it should be
preserved
um yeah if you can if you can work
control your HTML you should be able to
do this uh but like full complete
interaction especially with the big data
task attached
things even though you can you can
preserve a certain state of the plot the
complete interactivity like with the
drop downs instance those will not work
because they need to be computed in real
time does that make
sense yeah that ask suggested
yeah
uh that that uh yeah generally you
shouldn't be saving your outputs okay if
we export HTML will we lose the zoom
interactive I lost the question yeah if
you export The Notebook as HTML will we
lose the zoom activity with data
Shader uh you can zoom in like the down
sample data right
um not really the like uh as you saw
there like once we zoomed in to a data
Shader generator plot um it was
triggering compute to give you a a more
granular like detail oriented view
you're going to lose that if you
committed that yeah as K suggested if
it's going to do a do compute behind the
scenes it won't be static
anymore any other
questions oh thank you Sabrina that's
very kind of
you it's been extremely informable and
Casual to be honest so yeah I really
appreciate that thank
you
uh any other
questions uh I think yes is there a way
to make math. lip graphs interactive
there are limited yet useful interactive
elements in M but I don't know them
personally I yeah you can look it up uh
on the
documentation uh using
Hollow
uh I know you can generate so Hollow Wiz
is like the set of tools right like um
Hollow Wiz is the entire ecosystem H
plot can generate certain Matt lib plots
but like Matt Li itself has like limited
interactivity so I think a just does
what it can I haven't tried it myself so
yeah I I can't be super
sure any other
questions I do want to give a huge shout
out to like the developers maintainers
like the communities around D plot but
also like overall the P ecosystem right
like dark plot won't work if like and F
does not exist and if we can't use
jupter Hub and jup lab so all of this is
coming from like the P data ecosystem so
yeah all these tools are just awesome so
yeah want to acknowledge
that how H plot and Hollow work uh I
think the very first uh V like diagram
in this notebook right has a fairly yeah
this is like an accurate view of and Hol
is a set of tools in this diagram H plot
Hollow and data sharer are sorry H plot
Hol views names and words are
hard these three are a part of the
hollow Wiz ecosystem and if you go to
hollow. org you can see the actual
complete set of tools uh that are part
of the hollow viz
toolkit and their interactions are
honestly it's
it's I don't think I can just explain it
we'll need a visualization to show how
these relate to each other but they're
all like
interconnected